um so i have somebody that i know
and say that again i have somebody that
i know like they're you know my friend
and
they're into a lot of crime like stories
but like they're true stories um and
they listen to it a lot is that a sin to
be listening to that like even if it's
like very small amounts like is that
like a thing
i like that either is a small amount
i'm very glad you said
this is a bottle of water nice clean
vitamin and rich water
if i drop one drop of arsenic into this
just one drop
would you drink it
you would
no
but it's just one drop now
how many sins did adam commit before he
was thrown out of the garden
one
i mean how many fruits did he eat well
maybe one maybe part of one
what adam did was not monstrous in our
sense of the word monster he did not rob
a bank
it wasn't suicide or genocide or
infanticide or whatever patricide or
matricide or
he just did what vegetarians do
he consumed a fruit
and was
and were thrown out of the garden so
when my lovely sister says even though
it's just a little bit that's all the
devil needs let me tell you something
you know why the bible consistently
tells us thou shalt love the lord thy
god with
all thy heart and with all thy soul with
all thy mine are with all thy strength
why
because for god to save you listen to me
carefully he needs
all of you
to destroy you the devil just needs a
little peace
are you not with me it's my fault
to save you
god needs
all of you
to destroy you satan just needs a piece
of you
so god says
give me your whole heart
thou shalt love the lord thy god with
all thy heart
all thy soul
all thy mind
all thy strength all thy might that's
what we do not do
and so we have a lot of decent people on
the way to hell
look at what they were doing in the days
of lot
likewise also luke 17 28 as it was in
the days of lot they did
they dry
they bought they sold they planted they
built it which of those is a crime none
living life as usual
but god wasn't first
lost most people who are lost would be
decent people
for whom christ was not numero uno are
you following me my little sister my
young sister
a little bit of anything wrong is too
much
go to ephesians 5 let me show you
something exactly in line i'm so glad
you asked that question go to ephesians
5 someone else come to the mic with the
king james version ephesians 5
be therefore followers of god as their
children and walk in love as christ also
has loved us
and given himself for us and offering a
sweet smelling okay good read from verse
2 of verse 3 3 of ephesians 5. listen
carefully
but fornication and
carefully now let it not be one once
named among you has become not once
because once is too often
thank you very much child guidance page
200 paragraph two
that which
we do once
we are more apt to do again
that's a psychological principle
but you turn that around for the good
news
if you resist once
it's easy to resist the second time
then the third time it works both ways
and so a little of anything that's bad
is not good
catastrophic
disastrous that's how the devil gets you
little
many years ago this is actual true story
the only children's story i can tell
really i have only two children's
stories
i train some squirrels to eat out of my
hand
and i would go to the backyard
and they'd come out of the trees
i saw them nuts and one in particular
would come closer to all the others they
said this fella is bold
he'd come closer he actually came up to
my hand
i held a nut just like this
he came up
and for the nut he missed the nut and
grabbed my finger
and i felt the power but he didn't bite
down he realized this wasn't the nut
then he switched his grip and he took
the nut i was grateful to god and so he
went off
the next day
he came and i kept doing that that was a
summer
then i put the nut in the palm of my
hand
and did that
and he came and his tail was swishing
back and forth who is this guy and he
then he put his two front paws right in
my hand
took the nut turned around and dashed
off the trees and i said i've got him
and i kept on doing that then i kept
backing up i kept backing up now i lived
in the basement so there was a sliding
door and i stepped into the door
with a nut and he came
now all the orders in the house he could
smell see he was
nervous again they took it out of my
hand and ran
then i stepped but literally happened i
stepped back into the house he came into
the house
took that nut
that's what the devil does
it's never overnight
one step
one step one step once before you know
it you look back you say wait a minute
how did i get this far
you got that far
one step at a time a little at a time
but reverse that that's how we grow in
grace
one step at a time one step so let's
focus on that
you